[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
experienced profound trauma and she's
worried about her boyfriend we also
talked to a woman with a special needs
child is worried about her career
we talked to a husband whose daughter
experienced trauma and he wants to know
how to help stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone show where you talk about
your mental health your relationships
what's going on in your heart and your
mind and your families and your schools
in this country
so glad that you're with us
quick note if you're watching this on
the tubes
on the internets on the televisions
you'll notice i'm slowly transitioning
my entire wardrobe just to black dress
shirts just makes my life easier and uh
i used to just mostly have concert
t-shirts and they told me that i looked
unprofessional
and not us we loved them who told you
that not you america
my supervisor so
i'm trying to look more grown up and
evidently black makes me look dangerous
and tough and a lot
i don't look like i've gone outside very
much in the last three or four years my
nickname in high school was powder
remember that show you remember that
yeah it does black doesn't it's cool i
feel tougher and here's the thing i
don't want to make any more decisions
and so if i just have a closet full of
black shirts then uh be good i did that
once when i was in
my first working university and that
show bones came out and i just got all
the white dress shirts and all like
cheap black suits and
i just dressed like that all the time
it's very mark zuckerberg steve jobs of
you
well so i'm not gonna be wearing black
shirts anymore everybody not gonna be
doing that because uh
nope i'm gonna wear sparkly i mean i
think we should go all tie-dye i'm going
all tie-dye and
no i don't want to do tie-dye
kelly's going to start setting the
wardrobe so whatever i wear from this
point forward it's going to be because
kelly decided it let's go to rose in my
hometown nashville tennessee what's up
rose
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
thanks for calling what's in the world
is going on how can i help
i am a fairly new listener and i'm
hoping to get your advice welcome to our
game
you you almost doubled our listenership
that's so good it's incredible yeah me
and a few others so what's up
i am 30 years old i am in an amazing
relationship i have a boyfriend of
nearly two years we're very very happy
last year
um i was the victim
of a kidnapping robbery and sexual
assault oh my god and
um
i'm so sorry rose
thank you is that here in town
it was out of town so we we moved
afterwards and um
tried to
you know make nashville a new home yeah
um so it's been a journey and
i am very fortunate and grateful to
have found an amazing counselor that has
started
helping me on my healing journey
excellent and um
i was wondering how i can encourage my
boyfriend to seek counseling to help him
process this trauma for himself
yeah that's hard hard hard
first off what
if you're comfortable talking about it
what kind of paint me in context what
happened
sure sure so i um was a ride chair
driver and i was
picked up a passenger and um that
passenger was really volatile i didn't
know and
um held me at gunpoint and
just for
you know throughout the evening just
forced me into situations i was
very traumatizing very uncomfortable
with and um
thankfully
i considered a miracle i survived i
didn't have a scratch on me i wasn't
shot i wasn't beaten i wasn't
um
like physically
um
harmed in any way other than than the
sexual assault which was you know a big
deal as well okay good i'm glad you say
that yeah
yeah so i feel very very fortunate to
be in a situation that i'm in and i have
a great family that has been
um you know helpful and i've
found a counselor that's been fantastic
for me and so i feel like things are
starting to move in in a very positive
direction and i've been able to start
that healing journey
so what's your boyfriend going through
yeah i think
he knows you know the the gist of what
happened
um
i haven't been able to share in detail
this story
and he's kind of asked that i i don't
share that with him until he feels ready
and i want to be respectful of that um
but also know that you know this was a
very big
um you know it was a very big situation
for both of us and um he was the first
person i called and
he was there on the scene with me
as the police were coming and
um yeah so he was very involved his
family was very involved with everything
obviously everyone went to the hospital
with me and
just felt so loved and supported and i'm
so grateful for that but also
understanding that this was such a a big
impact to our relationship
um and and knowing that um you know that
there's
there's pain in the in the trauma so is
he showing signs of depression anxiety
frustration anger
is he demonstrating things are you just
proactively reaching on his behalf yeah
oh yeah so he um
he does have depression um like he's
been clinically diagnosed with
depression and he's kind of just asked
that i take it slow in terms of of
sharing this
experience and and the details of what
happened and so um whenever it kind of
comes up in conversation
um he gets really depressed and kind of
shuts down and
i can tell that there's there's hurt
there
and he hasn't you know we briefly talked
about him pursuing
um you know
accounts like seeking a counselor and
seeking some advice and he's just like
yeah i'll get to it when i get to it
and um
knowing that
you know in my experience of trauma the
longer you let it sit the bigger it
grows yeah and so just wonder how i can
you know lovingly encourage him um to
seek help
hey man he's lucky to have you and i'll
say on behalf of
a guy who's got a wife and a mother and
a sister and a daughter
um and he's just one of your neighbors
um i'm so sorry
that you know this but i
i need to say it that that should never
happen
and i'm you're a brave courageous person
to go get the help you need and i'm
proud of you and i'm glad you're one of
my neighbors now um
i'm so glad i'm glad you're with us
um so
i'm gonna paint some broad generalities
here okay and if he's got existing
diagnostics i can't get into those right
i'd have to talk to him but broadly
speaking i've seen this play out
multiple times one of the most common
things and i'll i'll take it out of this
this area completely and put it in a
different context but
the same the same general idea will
apply
i've seen parents whose kid gets hurt
somewhere like in a sporting event or in
a car wreck or something
and the parents are haunted by
i should have stopped this
i should have been there that's my job i
got one job on the planet to keep my
kids safe
and
i wasn't there for whatever reason and
99.9 of the time there's no there would
have been no reason to be there would
have been insane for you to be there but
that's where our heads go right
and so
using that example and swinging it back
if he's like most boyfriends
rightly or wrongly there's this overly
i've got my duty is to protect and like
that kind of stuff right
even though you you could possibly beat
him up in a fist fight that's it's not
about strength and muscles it's more
about role and disposition
and
i should have been there i should have
kept her safe what i couldn't even i
can't even right and there's these
moments these traumas these tragedies
that happen
that make us feel so small
and really
throw the curtains back like you know
it's like just ripping the covers off
the bed
we don't have control of much of
anything
we're flying blind in this deal right
the woman i love can be doing something
as benign as taking somebody from ihop
over to a concert hall and then this bad
thing can happen doing that you know
what i mean it makes us feel small and
powerless
and some of us when we feel small and
powerless we try to grab power
everywhere we can right i'm gonna
join a crossfit gym and crush it and
kill it and listen to pantera and slayer
and this will never happen again
and then often
the other happens
i just fold up and i can't talk about it
i want to hear it i can't hear it my
body reacts overreacts to the point it
swamps my system i can't do anything
so here's a
the the
the powerless truth on your part is this
you can't make him do anything
and that's right
for a woman who lost control
who is gonna try to i want you to watch
this in yourself
you're gonna have a tendency to
grab control where you can have it
because somebody stole it from you
okay
and is that am i am i onto something
with you totally okay exactly calendar
this you be on time you'll be on like
you'll find yourself doing that and one
of part of your trauma healing will be
being able to hey remember what happened
talk about it without your body
re-experiencing it that's the big one
but also you'll be able to contextualize
it
a bad thing happened to me for little to
no reason
and yet i'm gonna go about my day and
learn how to be graceful and learn how
to roll my eyes and learn how to laugh
again learn how to sleep again right to
teach my body that it doesn't have to be
on 24 7. that thing happened and
statistically speaking it's never gonna
happen again but it did and you hear him
saying right that's part of the journey
you can't make him do that and so here's
what the what i would suggest is one or
two gifts you have
you're seeing somebody right now in for
mental health care
i would invite him i would let him know
i really would like you to come to this
with me
you don't just say anything
you were part of my life i want you to
be a part of my future and so i want you
to be a part of my healing not make this
about him but this is about you because
you're the only one that you can deal
with you're the only one that you can
control so invite him to this and i
would let your therapist know i want him
to come i need to tell him this story as
part of my healing i need him to be a
part of this with me and he's unable to
hear it right now and so i want him to
be a part of this process and what
you'll hear is y'all will have to
negotiate back and forth for a season
um
as part of my healing i need you to tell
you what so you'll know fully know me
and he's going to say a part of my
healing as you i need you to be quiet
and you're gonna have to navigate
negotiate that together as you move
forward having a counselor do that with
you is really helpful
um not every relationship needs that
this one sounds like it does okay and
that's a good thing for you guys because
what you're doing is you're learning a
new language on how to have hard
conversations with each other how to be
graceful with each other and then both
of you need to have
that courage that you have right now he
needs to be courageous and also you need
to respect his boundaries and there goes
the circle right what you don't want to
have happen which i see happen all the
time in this situation
is you guys start comparing trauma and
you start comparing grief
he's going to have something happen he's
going to get covered he's going to lose
a like a part-time job he's gonna have
something
and he's gonna get down about it and
you're gonna think oh yeah you wanna
know what bad is
right
and your body's gonna turn him into the
bad guy
or
you're gonna start comparing grief
you're gonna start thinking things like
good god i'm the one this happened to
and even i'm moving on
and he's gonna be stuck in it and he's
gonna be saying
i think you're psychotic i think you're
a robot i think you've got problems if
you're already working on your heal
right so you're gonna start comparing
grief you'll have to be really
intentional about not doing that owning
each other's grief and owning the fact
that you're gonna heal differently and
here's the kicker
y'all both gotta get up and make your
bed you both gotta get up and go to work
you both got to get up and do things
that are going to keep you all well does
that make sense you both got to go back
to church you both got to do those
things that are going to keep you well
and healthy and so i think that can
start with him coming coming back to
coming to therapy with you not coming
back going to it and here's one other
thing you've heard me say this a million
times and i'll say it a million times
more
i would love for you all to you can't
have these conversations sometimes with
someone who's struggling with depression
the conversation overwhelms the systems
but writing it doesn't
and if you all kept a letter's journal
to each other that you'll share
i'm going to write what i'm feeling
right now i'm going to hand it to you
you can read it on your own time in your
own place when you feel safe and you owe
me something back
even if it's i can't even right now or
this is so hard for me to even read it
overwhelms me i'm not going to write
anything back today that's fine then
we're still we're still communicating
and slowly but surely might not be able
to speak in the same room with you and
see you and remember back to the
flashing lights and you in the hospital
but i can write it
and we're gonna slowly communicate back
and forth that way in this journal maybe
10 years from now 20 years from now 50
years from now be something your
grandkids read it'll be worth its weight
in gold does that sound like something
y'all can do
yeah that definitely sounds um
reasonable for us
um i think that's i think i think that's
fantastic and i think those two things
will get you all down the road
there may come a moment where you say i
can't move forward with us and this
happened um with somebody close to me
i can't move forward unless we sit down
and have this hard conversation
you tell me when but it has to happen it
has to happen soon
or i'm taking that as you choosing to
not be in relationship with me
and if he can't hear about it then and
you tell him this is a part of being in
relationship with me is
processing this trauma together
then he has to go get the help he needs
so that he can have that conversation
with you or by not getting help he's
choosing
out of the relationship
and that's going to be hard for
everybody
okay let's start with the first two
first with the journal and with inviting
him to therapy with you to your
counseling for your challenges for your
healing not for his for yours
and see if he'll be a part of that we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show the world is
bonkers right we all know this and one
of the most common questions i get is
how do i find a counselor in the chaos
i've reached out and there's a six month
waiting list or i can't afford it or
they only take insurance or i can't get
off work in time to go see somebody it's
way across town what do i do because i
want help with my anxiety my depression
my relationships are hanging on by a
thread i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to
mankato mankato minnesota and talk to
chelsea did i say that right
yes mankato
yes oh my gosh i'm incredible i should
do this for a living all right so what's
up how can i help
um okay so
i'll just start with my question for you
my husband and i have a special needs
daughter
and she's completely dependent
and i guess i've been struggling between
wanting
like personal accomplishments in a
career
and devoting myself to her
and i guess i'm just looking for some
insight on how i can find
a balance that's most beneficial for
everyone in the family
that's tough
tough
what's the special need
um
she has kind of a multitude of different
things
she has a really rare
syndrome
and in addition to that
she's autistic she's non-verbal she has
a feeding tube
um
yeah it's just kind of
new since last year that she
lost her hearing after meningitis
so
and there's a lot of different
things that we have to do for her on a
daily basis just for
to get her through the day yeah
this is a this is a hard question um i
want to um so
tell me say i don't really want to talk
about that and that's no problem
um what is her prognosis is this
terminal how long does she have
it's it's
more of a mental
or um
psychological and neurological
yeah um so it's really unknown
because there's really only about 20
people in the entire world that have her
syndrome
so there's just not very much science
behind it
as to where you know where her life is
going to lead and they all have a
variability of
you know disabilities and abilities okay
man
so
how old is she
she is eight eight
do you
do you struggle with guilt
do you struggle with
we did this
um i guess i
probably not guilt
but
maybe a part of me hasn't fully accepted
all of the
the things that she has to go through
every day
and it seems like when she gets over one
thing it'll be another thing right
that adds on top of it and it's
you know it's not something that i guess
i feel guilt with but um
i just didn't expect it really and so
um you know i'm just trying to arrange
my life in a way that is conducive to
everybody in the family so
so you you hit on something so important
and if you haven't done this yet it
would make you just like ever most every
other parent in your situation i've ever
talked to
um but i think it's the cornerstone
again this isn't i don't have any neural
signs to back this up or anything like
that but i think this is the cornerstone
to turning that corner and
deciding what comes
next and you've heard me say this on the
show but grief is simply the gap between
what i hoped for what i wanted to happen
and what actually is happening
it's that picture that i thought was
going to be
when we found out we were pregnant and
we thought i was gonna be a little girl
versus the reality at eight years old
here's this kid and all of her struggles
and all of her pain and all of her hurts
and all of her frustrations and i'll say
it for you
i'm so pissed off
and i'm so annoyed and i'm so frustrated
and i'm exhausted and i miss my husband
and i miss just kicking my feet up and
watching tv
and i miss
random sex on a saturday afternoon i
miss all those things because i've got
it's all of it right
and there's that gap
that we never stop and grieve and sit in
it
we just run to the next thing and run to
the next thing what happens is we run
for 8 10 15 20 years on adrenaline and
cortisol
and eventually our health takes a dive
our relationships melt as you mentioned
these dreams i had for myself these
career goals these things i wanted to do
i just let it all kind of
slowly drain out of the bathtub because
i never stopped to say
i wanted this i had this picture and
then this is what i've got
and now what right
most of us won't do that because we feel
like we're abandoning our kids or we're
bad parents for saying i wish you
weren't wheelchair-bound
i wish that you could get up and run run
and play i wish i didn't have to do all
this stuff because you have
hearing impairment and you have vision
impairment and you have um an inability
to eat i i wish that we feel like if we
say that that we're dishonoring our kid
and we're not if we don't say it we're
dishonoring our own bodies
okay
and so i think it's important to spend a
moment a season some time in that gap
and that gap is hard it hurts it's
brutal
sometimes even saying it out loud will
set off every mom alarm you have ever
and your husband joins every dad alarm
you have
how is your marriage through this
it's good um
my so my daughter um
she came into our marriage i had her
before i married my husband
okay um and so
he knew about her issues and things
obviously before we got married and he's
really um
just kind of he'd dive right in to
help me out with everything and uh
pretty awesome guy huh yeah yeah that's
cool very cool
very cool so
i would love to see you all get together
no kids no nothing you all have other
kids together
um we have a five-year-old son okay
normal just maniacal
bouncing off of things five-year-old
yes
that's fun so i would love to see you
all get together and do a
marriage checkup how are we how are
things what do you miss what do you not
like
often folks on either side of this
equation you know
mom dad whoever
get really invested in accomplishing a
bunch of tasks all day and couples can
accidentally find themselves as great
co-managers of their household
but really distant from one another so
i'd love to see y'all go to spend some
time together and just say where are we
checkup how are things we got another
diagnosis we got another challenge and
then we got meningitis on top of it and
we thought we're gonna lose her and now
she's lost her hearing so now we have
more challenges
where are we
and then grieve together and that might
be grieving together might be you
writing a letter him writing a letter
and y'all reading it to each other
here's what i wished
i wish this and it didn't happen
and then y'all can write that next one
together and i'm i'm saying that one's
that one's more if you don't really have
to write a letter together but then you
all say what's next and often i'm glad
you're not suffering from guilt often
what i hear for parents of kids
especially they feel guilty for wanting
to go to work they feel guilty for well
i want my career i feel guilt they feel
i guess there is a little bit okay so
you do have a little bit of that i mean
i left my career
i was a lab tech
and
it just wasn't working because she has
to go to therapy and things and so it's
like i just don't
i had to have the flexibility
and so i almost felt like i was choosing
between
like
having the income or the success or
whatever i envisioned for myself and i
it's like i had to give that up
it sounds selfish but no no see and
that's um here's what i want you to be
really weary of and when you do some
writing on this for yourself when you
start writing yourself a letter to start
grieving this
you got to be curious not judgmental
okay
you have to say huh why why do i get so
mad when i think about the career i gave
up not i shouldn't be mad about my
career right i don't want you to to
start labeling
morality to these thoughts you're having
they're just your thoughts man
and they're they're a thousand percent
valid you're allowed to have those it's
got to be i can't imagine right i get
frustrated when my kids like four
minutes late to the thing
right when they won't find their shoes i
can't imagine having to quit my career
that i loved or that i wanted to
go far in because
right that like
that is natural it's normal hiding that
and squashing that and trying to shut it
down will eat your body from the inside
out
and that brings me to this
if you choose ultimately
after you sit down with your husband
y'all talk about what is and what's
gonna be
if y'all say this is the season that
we're gonna try some in-home care and
i'm gonna go back to work
well i am working okay
i took a huge pay cut yep yeah so i
guess that's where i'm feeling it so i
want you to look at the math of this
like if if we have to get some in-home
nursing care or some in-home nanny care
or we have to ultimately send our
daughter to a home because we don't have
the resources to or the skill set or
what to care for her
then let's have that conversation let's
have that hard conversation that will be
brutal and gut-wrenching all that but
is this the reality of where we are
um i would suggest you you sound like
someone who would really struggle if no
she absolutely knows where she is she
knows who we are she knows all that
stuff
i just don't really want to deal with it
you'll you sound like someone who will
really struggle with that is that fair
um
yeah i mean it's constantly on my mind
like i'm not completely opposed to it
um i've had to get used to
the idea of it um just the fact that
maybe she's not going to be
in our home when we're not able to take
care of her anymore sure um
but i've
i've been trying to
um accept that i guess okay
um lean into that discomfort and leaning
to the discomfort of i may need to get
some help
three days a week i may need somebody
else to help drive and we're in a we are
in a
privileged financial position to be able
to do that or we work really hard and
save on other things so that we can make
this happen
and that's going to give me some space
in my marriage it's going to give me
some space with my five-year-old it's
going to give me some space in my
professional career
but have the hard conversation most of
the time in these situations those
conversations stay very hypothetical and
one person sits on all of that until
they implode and then the house is just
covered in contempt and resentment and
ash
i would love to see you have those kind
of like i really want to explore getting
some help
even if it's five hours a day for a for
somebody to come in skilled babysitter
or something to come in and help
or i won't have a conversation about a
home i want to have i want to have that
conversation
um if you ultimately get down the road
and you say
there's no way i'm leaving my special
needs kid
just so i can go sit in meetings all day
i'm not doing that that's insane
don't apologize for that either because
i've heard that side too like i feel
like i should be back at work but i
actually like being here and
i had to give a lot right so it's both
and i want to push on your one word
though
you're probably not going to find
balance that's mostly a myth it's not
real
you will find what works for you in
particular seasons
you will never find an outfit that will
work for 365 days a year
sometimes you have to put on a coat
sometimes you have to
just wear a t-shirt sometimes you have
to go inside because it's hot
you'll never be able to find a system
that will work forever and so letting
that myth of quote-unquote balance go
between work and home that's just not
real what's real is in this season for
the next 24 months i'm gonna double down
and try to go back to work full-time and
make a jillion dollars and i'm gonna try
the skilled nursing thing if we can
afford it i'm going to give that a shot
in this season
and then if she has another medical
setback and she needs her mom then for
this season i'm going to go back to part
time and i'm going to stay at home
and if you look at it seasonally
nobody says winter's broken
when summer shows back up or nobody says
summer's broken when winter shows up
it's just the cycle it's just the way it
goes i want you to
think of what's happening in y'all's
world the same way
what is the next 24 months think in
short term cycles what's the next 24
months what's the next 36 months what's
the next year what does that look like
for us right now and then what can i do
right now
to be successful in that area and that
might mean you got to say no to some
stuff that might mean that i'm gonna
spend less time with her and you know
push and push over to somebody else
i would lean lean towards that road and
i would let the word balance just let
that go it's a myth it's a vapor it's
not real and we kill ourselves trying to
get it we buy a bunch of stupid day
planners with millions of ribbons in
them and all kind whatever
let it go let it go
you're a good mom and that baby girl's a
lucky lucky lucky to have you it sounds
like your job's lucky to have you too
go out with your husband y'all pick this
thing apart spend some time in grief
spend some time in the pain of i wanted
that
but this is
and then y'all can make some hardcore
decisions about what comes next we'll be
right back
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to
greensbury.com and you'll get 10 off
your first purchase check it out today
your nutrition is worth it
all right let's go to the city that
destroyed my childhood st louis missouri
and talk to michael hey michael what's
going on
hey dr john how are you i was an astros
fan and i could never get out of the
playoffs because you guys
albert pujol y'all ruined my childhood
so i hope y'all are happy you guys in
the braves hope that was fun for y'all
so what's up man
um so a couple weeks ago my daughter had
an unfortunate accent where she lost
part of her finger oh no what happened
uh she got it stuck in the spin bike um
downstairs so they weren't able to
yeah
oh my
gosh
where is it
which part does she lose
like one knuckle two knuckles the top
knuckle okay fingernail part of it on
her ring finger oh
i'm so sorry she okay yeah
she's she's doing fine physically okay
um she it's gonna heal fine she's going
to have most of her mobility with it
um but
i'm more worried about her mental state
than anything yeah with it um because um
she's five and um you know it's
it's hard for me to put myself in her
shoes as how she's actually dealing with
the
the issue that you know the trauma yeah
and and so
you know when we were in er we were
honest with her we kind of talked to her
kind of gave her what was happening and
i don't know how that resonated with her
and so
um
when we did the vaccine shots she was
very petrified of the getting the shot
you know she built up this in her mind
as far how scary the needle is but she
has a high
pain tolerance like when she runs she
falls she gets up i mean she wasn't like
screaming because she lost her finger it
was when um she kind of built up that in
her head of what was kind of going on
and so
what really kind of sparked me to kind
of reach out to try to figure out okay
how do i
how do i talk to her how do i help her
through that side was when we went to
the the follow-up appointment for them
to look at it they took the bandages off
i mean she was screaming her head off or
without really any pain that you could
tell because i mean they weren't even
touching her hand right and so it's it
and when we put the bandages on at home
um it it's a huge ordeal
it's a lot of
pauses and breaks and stuff like this it
takes both my wife and i to to do this
and it's like
we try to talk to her through like hey
we're just changing the band-aids so i
don't know what's going through her mind
and i think there's there's anxiety
there and i just don't know how the
five-year-old mind is thinking about it
and so
what i should be doing and how to how to
relate and how to talk to her you're a
great dad man she's lucky to have you
it's awesome thanks for the call
so from this point forward i want you to
get the idea that a five-year-old is
thinking about things out of your mind
okay
um
you and i at our age would be thinking
things
she's five and
essentially she's responding
so she remembers people around her body
let's let's go there her body remembers
that hospital what happened
it goes in those lights that tile floor
those sounds those beeps the all
everything in her body screams run get
out of here because remember last time
and the last time mom and dad were
huddled around her finger saying oh my
goodness oh my goodness and kids absorb
our attention
here's a great example of this it worked
beautifully it's one of the times me and
my wife were on the same page
my son was outside running around he was
probably four maybe or five
and he tripped and dude he face planted
on a brick planter box outside right on
the corner just drilled him right in the
widow's peak and if you've ever seen a
picture of me i look like eddie munster
i got a dope widow speak
he nailed it and comes inside and you
know head wound it was spurting blood
everywhere
and
i i he'd watched ufc fights with me and
so we had already talked about he had a
little bit of language understanding the
head wounds just bleed naturally because
it's your body saying hey watch out this
is important stuff up here this is where
the eyes in my brain are right
so he walks in his head's got blood
dripping on his head and my wife and i
both looked at him and without even
saying anything we both started cheering
we both went yeah
and so he instantly stopped crying
and kind of froze there for a minute and
i was like dude you got a head thing
and he's kind of like smiled and was
like
ah he was just confused because there's
blood coming down his face right and we
went and looked and we wiped it away
like most head wounds it was a teeny
tiny little thing but it just bled
profusely right
but both my wife and i we knew
kids absorb the adult energy in the room
and your daughter remembers
when last time when this thing actually
kicked off and it hurt i mean that
searing pain and remember how scared and
terrified mom and dad were
and every time y'all are gonna do the
band-aid thing she can feel mom and dad
tensing up for the fight and that sets
off i'm not safe not safe not safe and
here we go again okay
so i want you to not think of her and i
need to tell you dude i've made this
mistake for years until i sat down with
some child therapist and i felt terrible
i felt awful especially for my son he
got the brunt of it because he was
younger by the time my daughter came
along i had learned some new things
i would blame him for thinking things in
his three-year-old brain or his
six-year-old or seven-year-old brain
man take that out so
coming back
this will take some time for her to heal
and i would just say be patient
be patient and not overwhelmed and not
oh right this is going to happen and she
needs to understand we got to change
these
bandages a couple here's a couple of
things you can do when it comes to the
band is changing
kids crave boundaries they crave
autonomy and they crave safety and those
things don't often work together right
boundaries make a kid feel safe but
autonomy i get to choose
that doesn't always align with well yeah
but you can't run down the street right
because you can get run over so here's a
quick thing you can do you can offer two
things and let her choose them
would you like
this
band-aid or this one and do you want to
pull it off
you want dad to pull it off
or do you want the puppy dog to pull it
off she gets to choose we're still
pulling that thing off but let's give
her a little bit of wiggle room in there
have you all tried that
i mean we we've done we've given her the
option of i mean do you want mommy or
daddy to do it okay do you want to sit
on daddy's lap and and those kind of
things sure um it's kind of because
that's we've gone down that path so
maybe pick which popsicle do you want
and i man we're dealing with some trauma
here and so i don't mind putting a
popsicle up there or which music do you
want to listen to
um or when we get done with all of this
do you want to dance to this song or to
this like whatever the things are that
work for her
and just know that those aren't going to
be magic fixes
it's going to be
kicking and screaming and clinching and
mom and dad helping and then
mom and dad are going to instantly drop
your shoulders and y'all are gonna start
cheering and you're gonna grab a
popsicle and all three of you are gonna
have one
and you're gonna celebrate this thing
together and we're gonna go to bed and
dude in about two weeks you're gonna be
so annoyed by this in about two days
you're gonna be annoyed by all this can
we just please change the freaking
bandage so i get back to my show right
this is a long arc on this deal and it
just sucks it just is but she's been
through some trauma
a lot of the traumas because of the pain
a lot of traumas because of the blood a
lot of the traumas because of the
hospital stuff but i'll tell you some of
the traumas also she's never seen mom
and dad scared like that
she's never seen mom and dad cry she's
never seen mom and dad terrified or
tensed up like that that's new
she didn't know she had that kind of
power right and that's scary for a kid
and so you guys coming in with you know
you got to hold tight and you got but
we're going to do it not we're not going
to prep for war um
i want to back out
you know this and so this is just two
dads talking here kids are ruthless with
each other
brutal they're the worst right the worst
and some of your concern now i'm
guessing just as a fellow dad is
projecting you know what's coming for
her
you know some crappy little kids are
gonna make jokes about it they're gonna
peg her as the girl with the you know
they're gonna just say all kind of mean
crappy things and you know that's coming
yep and so we can do one of two things i
can shield her from it
or i'm going to get on amazon i'm going
to find some books
um that are written for kids who have
limb loss or have some sort of
you know
physical exceptionalities they're going
to look a little bit different i'm going
to read her those books so that she can
see herself in out there right because
right now she feels like the only kid
with i'm going to show her no there's
other kids out there with
i'm also going to trace our hands and
i'm going to trace my finger down like
hers
and we're going to show how cool hans
are and how beautiful she is
we're going to teach her how to tell the
story
and here's why we're going to tell that
story we're going to tell that story at
home you're going to maybe ask her more
like hey tell me what you remember about
that do you remember what happened have
her tell her you that story and if she
says i don't want to that's fine but
we're going to teach her to tell that
story so that when she's nine and she's
by herself and two idiots on the bus
she's gonna say yeah dude i got my
finger stuck in a bike and it tore the
top off i'm freaking hardcore
or right you know what i mean we're
going to teach her that resilience and
the resilience doesn't come from flexing
it comes from storytelling it comes from
dude mom and dad love each other and
they love me and they think i'm
beautiful so
i don't care what you think
you hear i'm saying
yeah like so i have i've started reading
the book called the whole brain child
uh-huh i'm not sure and it basically
talks about how
building like you know talking about
those past memories and bringing those
things up but she seems to shut down
yeah when it when we try when we try to
have that conversation is that just
because
it's so new in her mind that we need to
kind of let that
feel you know like like that pass a
little bit to start engaging in that to
to talk about that
everything yeah everything about her
finger is
chaos
everything in her finger sets off every
trigger she has in her sweet little
brain
mom and dad aren't safe house isn't safe
i go to the hospital i want to talk
about it i don't i want out of this
thing
every time mom and dad look at the
finger they they squint their eyes they
go they go they go ah
everything about it is is is whoa
and that's where story helps norm things
like it just is it is
and so maybe y'all can color together
and you can begin to trace your hand
where you have tucked under one of the
same fingers she has
and you could say
man my hand is not near as cool as your
hand
or look my hand's like your hand
look out like we're cool right and so
what you're doing is you are talking the
story we're not laughing at at all we're
not making light of we're not minimizing
we are simply saying i see all of you
and i still love you
both right you don't have to hide
anything from old from your from your
ding-dong old dad because i love you
right and even so i'm going to continue
to talk about this eventually she'll
talk about it eventually you'll
she you'll hear she'll hear you talking
about to your wife
i cannot believe how strong and
brazilian and gritty and beautiful that
little girl is she's gonna hear those
things and hear those things and then
when y'all play
um
you can reenact it that's child play
therapy right where
you know one of her dolls gets her
finger caught in a thing and you can
look at your daughter and say what do we
do
and then her daughter can help be a part
of the healing process of that little
doll and she begins to gain autonomy
over this thing right so you hear what
i'm saying we're going to slowly norm it
in the house this is a new is in the
house we're not going to shy away from
it we're not going to shuck away from it
it's just going to be the new is i just
would be really careful about forcing
her into things right now that finger is
just radioactive it's trauma and let's
let mom and dad be the the big ones
around there
understand this kids are going to be
ruthless they're going to get onto her
all children
suffer from body image from i'm
different and this idea of wholeness i'm
no longer a whole person
and that's where you teaching her that
wholeness doesn't come from your body
parts wholeness comes from the inside
out
and
cards and little gifts and let's go
serve other people show her that she's
got function in the world that she's got
purpose that people need her around
and man that's just gonna become a story
for her hear what i'm saying okay
yeah and what what about like you know
the the joking of it like if you know if
you can joke you know i've heard people
talk before you if you joke about
yourself others can't make fun of you
like
is there anything there is that's how i
handle problems that's not how my wife
that's not how my wife handles problems
yeah and part of my humor is a defense
neck mechanism because i'm pretty
insecure um some of it is because i just
naturally i mean that's just how my body
handles traumas by cracking up and
laughing about it my wife doesn't
and so
um
maybe you laugh about your role in this
can you believe daddy cried when his
little girl got hurt can you believe
daddy cried right maybe that's the joke
that
um but if she's not down with laughing
at it i wouldn't make it a joke i would
let her offer that as a joke
okay if you get hurt at some point which
you will you'll hurt your knee at noon
ball or you'll you know i don't have a
lawnmower
if you do and you choose to make jokes
that may give her permission to um but i
wouldn't force her into jokes about it i
wouldn't tease her about it no not yet
not as a six-year-old
right okay
yeah it's it's just been it like we have
an older child and
he's more logical she's very emotional
and so it's able to have more direct
conversations with him
about things with her it seems to be on
that emotional track and it was trying
to get i'm just
i was getting on the same playing field
with her as far as like how to
relate to her and communicate with her
has been
also kind of i felt like a struggle for
me i feel like i'm missing something
when with her is how she reacts to these
things which is how i've seen him
react to things we are all about weird
very few conversations a whole lot of
hugging
very very few conversations a whole lot
of like i'll just tell you what i did
last night
uh i crawl my daughter set up this
wolf den under our kitchen table and i
was on all fours under the kitchen table
with my daughter and some little
animal she had and i was
the wolf king and she was the wolf queen
and we were protecting the baby from i
don't know what armadillo i don't know
what was going on outside the cave
um
that's connection
right that's
she doesn't need me to lecture her on
how much i love her she needs me just to
be
um and i would tell you this about your
son one if he hasn't experienced trauma
you'll see emotions when he gets when he
has that trauma and the second thing is
often highly intellectual young children
are hiding behind their intellectualism
okay and so in the same way that you
want your daughter to slowly start to
come around with
those like
what's actually real here like i i hear
your feelings and we still have to
change this band-aid
i want you to lean on your son the other
way so you have some very
logical reactions to this
what's happening inside your body right
now how do you feel about that yeah
right and lean on him the other way
because we were looking for balance in
our kids we're looking for they can do
both right
um but i tell you what brother
man your kids are lucky lucky lucky to
have you as a dad all dads out there
i hope you'll man step up to the plate
like michael is you're good man get on
amazon and find some of those children's
books
and you'll i don't know i don't know if
there's one called so i lost a finger
but you'll find some that have some sort
of
loss like that and you'll their pictures
of kids still playing ball still running
around having fun still laughing still
going to birthday parties
and that social norming for a kid is
everything
everything we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now now's your chance to get up and
choose differently and that doesn't have
to be complicated in fact in my new book
own your past change your future we'll
walk through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be johndaloni.com to start creating
the life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back um man if you've
been listening to this show you hear me
ranting and raving about my new book own
your past change your future
that is out and into the wild and man
um the feedback has been again i keep
saying that i never could wrap my head
around this um this is the most nervous
i've ever been about anything putting it
out there and uh
the reception has just been something
else i'm so so grateful
um i want to take a second something to
touch on in the book here and i've
gotten some pushback on social media
some a lot of accepting exception
accepting whatever on social media
then i found myself why am i why am even
checking in and out with social media i
want to talk about
where we are as a society as a country
when it comes to this idea of friendship
and i think we get lost in social media
and this and that and the digital and
the tech and all that and the metaverse
i just want to drill it down
until
literally until like 15 years ago
friendship the idea of tribe the idea of
community the idea of we are in relation
with one another
that had to take place
with people in a room
i could write letters there's
ample evidence of people writing letters
throughout history that are beautiful
and great and
loves reading books you know of old
letters that's all great
but all of those interactions
pointed people back to
when we are back
together and so i had to if i was going
to be friend if i was going to be in a
tribe if i was going to be a community
if i was going to be a neighbor i had to
endure the awkwardness and the ugliness
of human interaction
and choose to remain anyway or i had to
remain anyway one of my
great mentors
richard back dr richard beck said what
if we lived our lives as though we could
never move
how different would our conversations be
if that my neighbor was always going to
be my neighbor
if the church i go to was always going
to have to just be in my church how
different would my would my
conversations be
would i be less ragey would i be less
judgmental i'd be less angry and running
around and like i'm out of here i'm
going to the next
if that was the only restaurant i could
eat at would my conversations be
different right and now
instead of hanging out in person
disagreeing in person
you know and never questioning whether
they're gonna show up
tomorrow boom overnight
friendship changed we moved the whole
enterprise online
and we traded quality of friendship we
traded this interaction for quantity
and we're drowning in shallow water now
and
again i'm not jumping on that i hate
social media bandwagon i think i started
i never got on the wagon in the first
place it's redefined the word friend for
us right and now a friend is a curated
person to who reports hating the same
things i hate or
you know carrying the same bag i carry
or liking the same workouts i like
but we engage with them on their terms
and they engage with us on our terms and
from far away and our relationship is
made up of comparing and sharing and
judging without the discomfort of doing
it in the same room and that discomfort
is iron sharpens iron is really
or i don't really mean it like that i
meant it like this or let me push back
on that right
and that's not to say that some in
online interactions aren't real and deep
in fact there's some studies that show
people are willing to
vomit more they're willing to be more
honest online quicker right
there's just not a lot of gas in the
engine of that relationship over time
those meaningful interactions me telling
you a whole bunch of stuff about myself
or me texting you a bunch of pictures of
me with no clothes on while they're
giving you information about me that you
wouldn't otherwise have had
it's not real friendship it's not real
relationship
real relationship is showing up real
relationship is being present it's being
fully seen and fully loved
and the story that digital friendships
digital relationships are equivalent to
real-life relationships it's not real
it's not real
and i've heard this um
i'm gonna hang out with garyvee one day
and then we'll
have a good discussion about a good
debate about it and um i've i've not met
him people in the building are friends
with them they say he's great he's a
incredible human where i disagree with
him is on this issue is he says that man
people have been saying this forever
like the kids in the phones in the in
the the tele once they put telephones in
every house kids are gonna just all go
to and all the way back in time man if
we give these kids
books instead of just the oral
traditions they're going to be ruined
and then now with the metaverse right
we're going to move all of our i'm going
to take out loans or use credit to buy
imaginary curtains in an imaginary piece
of real estate
in a fantasy land like in meta in a
thing that's not real
and he says uh man and he's not the only
one i'm just picking on him but he's not
the only one but it's just the same old
thing and in 10 years we're going to
wish for the simplicity of our cell
phones because then we're going to be
wearing those
you know xlr headsets we're going to be
living in the metaverse and all and we
might be that might be true we might be
but here's where i think it's different
all of those other things letter writing
books this telephone in the house
it all pointed back to
real people getting together in a real
room i got on the phone so that i could
tell people when i was gonna be at the
mall i got on the phone so we could talk
about that guy so that when we were at
school tomorrow when we all showed up on
the same team when we all showed up at
work together it all was about going
back to the same room to the same place
to reconnecting
now it's about
hey we're doing this whole other thing
where we never have to be in the same
room we never have to connect we're
going to outsource all we're going to
wallpaper over all the discomfort and
feelings and create a whole new universe
i don't feel like i'm winning in the
real world so i'm going to create a a
imaginary fantasy land where i think i
can compete and win
and don't make make no mistake
competition is wired into our dna
it just is comparison is wired into us
that is who we are it's how we
survived
and so it will translate here
there will be people who've got cooler
imaginary curtains and imaginary cars
and cooler imaginary houses and cooler
imaginary muscles that you can buy or
upgrade or whatever whatever the thing
will be
so hear me say this in no uncertain
terms
being well involves real people in
person someone to sit with us when we're
hurting bring us a meal when the world's
on fire
laugh with us until our stomachs hurt
someone who shows up when our kid has
passed away when our mother's sick when
our wife is in the er and they say
nothing they just show up
they just sit with us
right
if we're not intentional about
cultivating those relationships look
around this is what we get
half of the country in some sort of
clinical diagnostic with anxiety
depression
half of the country screaming at the
other half of the country people blaming
yelling screaming that's what happens i
will go on record as saying i believe
the chief
the chief enemy of our time is
loneliness
is the lack of connection period
full stop end of story
the rest of the stuff all all the pain
hate anger frustration all of it stems
from that
we got to cultivate those things if
we're not intentional about it look
around the loneliness will poison us
and so
in my book
own your past change your future
i talk about this but more importantly
more importantly than just labeling the
issue we walk step by step here's how to
go make friends and i know that sounds
trite and lame and silly that's where we
are that's where i am how do i go make
friends how do we stay connected how do
we build those relationships how do we
say okay i buy it i get it
the what i'm doing isn't working and
going further down it's not working
what do i do now it's going to be lay it
out my goodbye kevin man
this book is for him it's for me it's
for him he said deloney i turned all the
screens off and now i'm just sitting in
my living room staring at my three
daughters what i do now
my buddies all moved away what i do now
this book is for that this book is for
him this book is for you right
i'm going to cover this story and a
bunch of other stories in this thing
if you pre-order today you'll get a ton
of bonus items a ton of stuff i think is
are we still in pre-order here yes okay
so it's not out into the wild yet it's
almost out into the wild still can
pre-order it here
even up to a month of free therapy with
better help
it's good stuff man they've stepped up
to the plate here
it is time
it's time
go to johndaloney.com to pre-order own
your past change your future today i
believe at this one go check it out
all right as we wrap up today's show
my good friend
randy lynn there in oklahoma yes ma'am
this is for you my sister
this song is for her
it's called surface pressure off the uh
and kento soundtrack is el canto and
kento and kento soundtrack
we actually got married me and randy
lynn she was uh
the stand-in at my wedding for my wife
and we couldn't see each other but we
were in rehearsal
we didn't really get married but that's
a whole other weird story so
written by lin manuel miranda the
genius genius genius song goes like this
i'm the strong one i'm not nervous i'm
as tough as the crust of the earth is i
move mountains i move churches and i
glow because i know what my worth is i
don't ask how hard the work is got a
rough indestructible surface diamonds
and platinum i find them and flatten
them i take what i'm handed i break
what's demanded but
under the surface i feel berserk as a
tightrope walker and a three-ring circus
under the surface was hercules ever like
yo i don't want to fight cerebus
under the surface i'm pretty sure i'm
worthless
if i can't be of service
a flaw or a crack the straw in the stack
that breaks the camel's back what breaks
the camel's back
get connected y'all we'll see you soon